we were in it's now been six weeks since
we were in Indianapolis for the Scouting
Combine back when teams were in usual
draft preparation mode it's been
anything but that in recent weeks and
and look there was a report from ESPN
over the weekend this is fairly obvious
multiple teams are preparing to do the
draft from home well if they aren't they
should be because that's one of the
major options it's either going to be go
to the facility in small groups or do it
from home and I think frankly the end
result is going to be do it from home I
think they got over their skis last week
when they started announcing that that
team employees executives coaches could
gather in small groups without
recognizing there are plenty of states
out there where NFL teams do business
that I've stay at home orders and those
states may not allow it so that's when
on Thursday they sent a memo to all
teams explaining it's gonna be one of
the other and I think it's gonna be the
other I think they're all gonna be at
home I think that's the way it's gonna
go and I know it's a better TV show if
you've got Jerry Jones and Steven Jones
and Mike McCarthy sitting well 6 feet
apart but still in the same room making
the call to the guy they draft I just I
think that that it's not gonna happen
it's not gonna work and it just occurred
to me Chris even if they can pull it off
there will inevitably be images of
people not 6 feet apart
closer than 6 feet apart and those are
just images we don't need to send out
there at a time when we're hammering
everyone to comply with these
requirements no I mean I agree with you
you're right I mean you know the
requirements are there for a reason you
know it's for the safety of a lot of
people in our country I get that you
know just to play devil's advocate
though like Mike like you know we see in
some of these draft rooms they're
gigantic they're top-notch
state-of-the-art type rooms right the
war rooms whatever it may be they
usually have these gigantic you know
tables where one guy can be sitting at
one end of the table and literally be
like 15 yards away from the guy at the
other end of the table
you know what wood States would
government Fran I'm asking this I don't
even know would there be a big issue if
they just say it was Mike McCarthy
Stephen Jones and Jerry
Jones in a huge room and they were 10 to
15 feet apart do you think people would
make a big deal about that and cause
them an uprise of a stir I just think
that if it complies with the stay at
home requirement if the states allow the
guys to leave their homes and get
together as long as they stay more than
6 feet apart wherever they are then then
so be it I just think the the better
approach the smarter approach the more
pragmatic approach and the right message
to send all the people out there who are
complying with stay at home orders and
if they aren't they should be everybody
stay at home do it virtually I've been
saying for years you can do it by group
text message if you want to from the
standpoint of making the picks now
deciding what you're going to do with
the pick is the thing that may get a
little more complicated especially if
you have trade discussions if build in
more time what the hell else do we have
to do Chris
go back to 15 minutes for round one what
else are we doing who cares if it takes
six hours nobody's got to get up for
work the next morning except for us well
we do who cares yeah the TV show is
longer than it otherwise would be we're
not going anywhere to cap it's the
ultimate captive audience well you're
right I mean we're gonna have to deal
with some rawness of this show I would
think but yes that would be some of the
obstacles that that at least you know
come come up in my mind I mean let's
just say you know let's just say okay
the number one pick the bangles traded
to the Dolphins right at number five and
what if the TV networks aren't you know
they're not ready and oh gosh we don't
have a connection with anybody in Miami
or do anything like that yeah it's gonna
be a little weird it's gonna be uh you
know not not a smooth TV program that
way so those unforeseen trades yeah we
might you know it might be hard to fill
time in between let alone you know what
are the the network's gonna do with
there analyst you know are they gonna
try to have the analyst you know in a
room in a studio somewhere where their
social distance does a certain amount of
feet away from each other you know
that's another element to I mean is it
just gonna be zoom and FaceTime
choppiness everywhere
to all different people throughout the
NFL these are things that the NFL needs
to work out well Peter King reports in
today's football morning in America that
it will likely be a joint combination of
ESPN NFL Network one feed that's going
to be on both networks instead of having
both networks have their own production
especially because NFL Network has been
knocked off the air for the past two or
three weeks they have no live content
because they've got a studio in LA that
no one is going to they've got another
one in New Jersey that no one is going
to so they don't have live programming
so they can't do it
ESPN has a very limited production that
is happening so I they'll be a couple of
people in studio there but I think it's
gonna be a lot of what you've been doing
what I've been doing broadcasting from
home as they figure out where they're
gonna go from here to here to here to
here to here and it's going to be as
Peter explains that a combination of NFL
Network on-air talent and ESPN on-air
talent but I think appearances from a
lot of these these home studios home
offices of coaches general managers
owners etc and also prospects coming in
via that virtual connection speaking of
prospects Ian Rapoport of the NFL
reported over the weekend that EA Sports
is going to have a virtual moment of the
prospect walking on stage meeting the
Commissioner part of the the Madden game
the whole concept of that the effect
school video game and each prospect is
going to choose a high school to receive
a $2,500 grant toward their football
program you know which hey the NFL's got
the money to do that because they're not
spending the money to take the players
and all their families to Las Vegas
that's the major expense that comes from
putting on the major TV show bringing in
all these players 20 25 30 guys and
family members and putting them up in a
hotel so you save some money there and
you can redirect it to something good
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports